Tatiana chervenco profesora de
matemáticas en una escuela rusa
y Dimitri maddienco exmilitante y
milicia Pro rusa de Danny asky ambos
tienen una versión de lo que es el Ruso
y vivir bajo la sombra de la guerra en
Ucrania
las personas que apoyan la operación
militar especial Ahora son muy
criticadas yo por el contrario siempre
he estado a favor
Dimitri perdió su pierna izquierda
luchando por Rusia andaniasca yo conozco
la verdad yo sé cómo era verdaderamente
Doña es antes de la operación militar
especial mi casa fue bombardeada cuatro
veces desde posiciones ucranianas pero
para Tatiana la guerra amenaza el futuro
de sus estudiantes
las autoridades rusas tienen un plan en
la sociedad quieren tener soldaditos de
juguete algunos irán a la guerra algunos
más fabricarán municiones y otros
crearán software de computadora para
todo eso seguirán órdenes sin tener
derecho a pestañear
este joven reservista decidió
desobedecer las órdenes del kremlin
prefiere permanecer bajo anonimato no
quiere ir a prisión o terminar en el
frente de batalla
me niego categóricamente a participar en
esta infamia y por eso haré todo lo
posible para que no me envíen al frente
y si no puedo resistir al estado y su
aparato administrativo prefiero ir a la
cárcel
él es uno de los tantos prófugos de las
autoridades rusas desde septiembre el
año pasado cuando Vladimir Putin anunció
la movilización parcial de reservistas
casi un millón de rusos han abandonado
su país desde el inicio de la guerra
400.000 de ellos tras la movilización
parcial
el gobierno ruso ve con buenos ojos esta
migración y la considera como una
autopurificación de la sociedad los
rusos en el exilio dicen que volverán
cuando Putin caiga y la guerra termine